vous allez vous inscrire je vais vous aider à
surmonter les obstacles avec les sacs non ça va je peux l'obtenir d'ici je suis censé
vérifier la chambre d'
accord
bienvenue mr ryan salut
juste votre signature s'il vous plaît d'accord
mr shreven espère que la chambre sera à
votre  satisfaction
ah oui et la vue est incomparable
wow
c'est gros pincements
ah
euh
assieds-toi
tu sais que tu as vendu ça comme un travail de bureau
tu dois choisir quelqu'un à qui faire confiance jack
maintenant assieds-toi
tu as amené ton chien
qp chien
quasi personnel pourquoi d'autre suis-je  sortir pour une
promenade
c'est mieux qu'ils tremblent après
que durham la
première personne que j'ai jamais tuée jack était
innocent
qu'a-t-il fait
elle
elle n'a rien fait elle était une
spectatrice
quelqu'un qui vient
juste de venir derrière moi trop vite
comment allez-vous  pour quelque chose comme ça,
vous avez de la chance de le dépasser
ce n'est plus la même chose
vous n'êtes plus juste un animus
vous êtes opérationnel
oh maintenant
ça va tokyo londres états-unis ça va être
un anéantissement vous les américains aimez
vous considérer comme directs
peut-être toi  sont juste grossiers peut-être juste en train de
toucher
jack tu as un autre problème tu m'as menti
pendant trois ans quelqu'un vient
bien sûr pas pouvons-nous avoir une minute s'il vous plaît
non c'est de la géopolitique pas une
thérapie de couple